that is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk and i'm dave
jewett the host of loadout the gamespot
show that delves into pop culture's most
iconic weapons and on today's episode
we're diving into an extended chat from
last week's episode that digs into the
behind the scenes secrets behind some of
star wars most iconic weapons this is an
m40 but m38 scopes were also used it's
actually an aiming telescope for
an m4 tank looks like a scope doesn't
actually function that way around and
that configuration as a scope and of
course they never use it yeah
if you like this kind of content make
sure to subscribe as we have new
episodes of loadout every sunday
including our previous episode all about
the impact and inspiration behind the
iconic arsenal of star wars and on top
of that we'll still be showing jonathan
new gaming arsenals every saturday so
make sure to check those out too right
let's talk star wars
[Music]
so han solo's famous blaster
the dl-44 actually based on the mauser
c96 that's right so can you walk us
through the greebly's professional word
that they added i know you said they
added a scope but how did they sort of
star warsify this for for han solo
there's a whole convoluted story behind
this particular prop that i invite
people to go away and go down that
rabbit hole in their own time but bottom
line was as we said before
the
the production designer visited visited
the armorer and looked for donor like
host guns that they could then attach
stuff to and the easiest way to change
the outline of something fairly iconic
like a broom handle mauser or c96
was to put a scope mount and a scope on
it now sacrilege for collectors this is
quite a nice
wartime commercial example they actually
had to drill a hole into the body of
this gun
to then attach the mount for the scope
to then sit over the top of it this was
never meant to have a scope on it and
that was done originally for a couple of
films involved there's the naked runner
the little known sinatra movie sinatra
principle has got to be killed the naked
runner both of them had slightly
different takes on this
baptism co idea
for a takedown
assassin's weapon so it would have the
buttstock or a butt stock this was
designed to have a holster buttstock we
haven't got it on the table here today
clip on
and then some sort of suppressor or
barrel extension to screw on you know
they love that spy stuff in the movies
and then to clip the scope on as well so
the idea was it was like a briefcase kit
to turn a handgun very much like um
generation one megatron from the
transformers
um i think i'd hear about megatron in
this conversation yeah i know this is
the beauty of this stuff but the bottom
line was some sort of scope some sort of
muzzle attachment which instead of being
like a suppressor or something was now a
german mg81 muzzle booster flash hider
stuck on the front they had to come up
with a new chunky welded on
barrel as well to support that and make
it not look too rubbish because the
scope mount fits to one side on the
other side there's a mysterious
blank space or is this a metal disc no
one's quite figured that one out i don't
think
and then there was like engine model
aircraft engine parts stuck to the front
to break up this outline here
and then there are different variants of
the dl44 as well it's not just han
solo's pistol luke has one as well and
then hans pistol changes throughout all
three or four movies
so that's it in a nutshell
and moving
swiftly on from
i suppose one side of the alliance to
the other is
boba fett's weapon of choice but it
doesn't look like there's been a huge
amount changed in this weapon to
get boba his blaster well it's funny
should say that because in in the
original movie renamed a new hope later
on as you know
um this is pretty much what it looked
like um there were a few minor
tweaks cosmetic tweaks to it but i guess
because most of the audience wouldn't
know what this is which is a webby and
scott number one mark one
flair launcher break open shove in
massive flare
close it up shoot it into the sky
uh people didn't know necessarily what
that was they must have served in the
armed forces perhaps so that kind of did
as a generic laser blaster just with a
scope on it again to give you that
sci-fi look
but then for that was in obviously
empire strikes back but for return of
the jedi they gave it a whole new barrel
assembly with like ribbing and knurling
and more of a busy
look to it with the same basic gun as
the base
i think the very iconic thing is the
sterling
which um went on to birth the e11
blaster
um so i'll give you that version
and i
get to grab
the cool star wars word
we can see a side by side of everything
that was done to
turn this into the
empire's sort of main infantry weapon of
choice yeah which isn't that much
actually yeah we haven't got the
magazine fitted that obviously that
comes out here and immediately
um signifies a
submachine gun really having a big mac
sticking out the size this version is
very small and i
i don't think we have a it's never
really said in the movies but i always
assumed there's a battery shooting
lasers gotta be yeah it's a power cell
or something yeah yeah some sort you
never see them reload them
but that's what it's assumed to be and
in real in reality what that was
uh is a five round so it's a 32 round
stone magazine cut down with the floor
plate stuck back on to give you enough
shots for the armor poor armor i'd have
to run in and out of shot with numbered
mags i actually have i'm a proud proud
owner of one of these at home with the
number six scratched into it so they
could keep track of what was loaded and
what was being fitted to the guns oh wow
and where they gave up or ran out of
time is where you see just laser bolts
animated in
and no actual
movement of the gun and no muzzle flash
so is this one of the
movie props
this one itself that is a genuine star
now all of these were taken apart after
filming
because they were a working armory they
hired stuff out so they took all the
grievances all of the stuff off
but we know because quite frankly the
entire inventory of sterling that
baptity was hired out for a new hope
that this is one of those guns
and then it was put back together
sometime in the 90s with one of the
original scopes
one of the original mags
at least the same stock of these plastic
these were drawer runners would you
believe from a from a hardware store i
believe
just stuffed in there to cover up the
cooling holes and make it look high-tech
and then for me the icing on the cake of
us having this in the national
collection of arms and armor is believe
it or not this slightly ropey looking
plastic
box on the side because that's not
original to the gun but it was made or
acquired and added by lucasfilm when
they borrowed this and the rebel version
back from bapti
to redesign it for for force awakens oh
wow yeah so this was used as a reference
so so the full stop in its little movie
history is it was a reference piece to
create the f11d
the sort of
uh rebooted version of the e11 that's
incredible and of course we have things
like
it's it's a weird movie quirk that the
stock folding stock becomes like a
forward hand grip and even yeah and
because obviously stormtroopers don't
shoulder their weapons
never so it is extremely fascinating and
seeing them side by side
you really can see how much of the dna
bled through
and it really is like a quintessential
sci-fi
relic now and for me personally as a big
star wars fan they almost peaked
very early with their with their weapon
design and how they went about
building their virtual armory there's
just something about this although the
changes are minimal it the resulting
lines of this just i don't know
i'm biased i grew up with them but so
this this is um
this is an m40 but m38 scopes were also
used it's actually a
an aiming
telescope for
an m4 tank
mounted to a simple strip of steel
it does the job looks looks like a scope
doesn't actually function that way
around and in that configuration as a
scope and of course they never use it
yeah you never see a blaster higher than
than chest height but all the grieby's
wasted on stormtroopers apparently and
of course what we're missing are the
greeblees that
would have been glued on and immediately
flew off when they started shooting them
like the power cylinders that sat on top
of the magazine housing notably
but there were also other bits stuck to
the to the receiver tubes and the
reference photos that then are missing
from most of the screen used guns so
there we are beautiful piece of cinema
and firearms history that yep
good on sterling
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout if you enjoyed
it please do like the video and
subscribe and maybe even let me know in
the comments section down below or on
twitter at a regular dave what you'd
like to see an episode on if you want
more video game firearms content you can
watch our back catalog of previous
episodes or check out our weekly series
of firearms expert reacts where i show
our friends at the royal armouries a
slew of guns to break down if you
enjoyed this episode we've got two
episodes of jonathan breaking down stars
battlefront 2 weapons as well but until
next time i've been your host dave
dewitt thanks again for watching and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
you